hey we're bringing science down to earth
what is this Neil this is we love
science
hey everybody I'm Chuck nice welcome to
our newest show star talks wheel of
science this is an interactive show
where we answer your questions about the
universe and because I'm not smart
enough to even answer my own questions
about the universe we have here to help
out the one the only your own personal
astrophysicist dr. Neil deGrasse Tyson
what's up Neil Chuck
as usual you don't know the questions
that's right I'm sitting here clueless
aha but I am positive that you know the
answers our topic today is luck holds
let's do this bring it on hey Neil
before we get into it can you just let
the people know what is a black hole
black hole is a region of space where
matter has condensed to such a high
density that the gravity at its surface
the surface gravity is so high that you
cannot escape it even at the speed of
light you are forever trapped it is the
fabric of the space-time continuum
warped back on itself and what you fall
in you are never coming out it is the
human version of the roach motel
you check in but you don't check out
a black hole that's why we call them
black and when you follow you no come
out that's why we call it a hole because
we tell it like it is in astrophysics
black hole spin that wheel
[Music]
Daniel Junius wants to know what happens
when we fall into a black hole
whoo you want to avoid that first of all
never don't do that neither at home or
at work or anywhere else but if you
happen to fall in a black hole which is
my preferred form of death it's better
than getting hit by a bus right so if
you've fallen in a feet first dive to
this cosmic abyss you will not survive
because you will not miss the tidal
forces of gravity will create quite a
calamity when you stretched head to toe
are you sure you want to go those tidal
forces will increase to the point where
your body will just snap in two likely
at the base of the spine then each of
those two pieces will snap into two so
you become one to two to four to eight
to sixteen until you bifurcate all the
way down to the center of the black hole
and you become a stream of atoms and
that's not even the worst part
the worst part is you are funneled
extruded through the fabric of
space-time so that you used to be this
wide now you're this narrow and so this
phenomenon this this extrusion like
toothpaste through a tube we have a word
for it
death by black hole it's called
spaghettification spaghettification
sounds like a meal to die for see what I
did there kill me but give this video a
like for a dad joke I Neal you ready for
the next one spin that wheel if a
coaster wants to know this there is a
black hole in the middle of our galaxy
is there a giant black hole or something
giant in the middle of our universe and
something in the middle of the
multiverse if we follow that logic
no no why will you offer me it's a no no
no but I'm sure there's more to it
what's up there is no center of the
universe all the universe was in the
same place at the same time nearly 14
billion years ago then you could think
of it sort of as a center but after that
we are expanding and all pieces
expanding away from every place else it
feels like we're at the center but we're
not anymore than when you're a ship at
sea and you are in the middle of your
own horizon you're equidistant from
every edge of your horizon that doesn't
mean you're in the center or anything so
no there's no known center of the
universe and therefore I can say with
some confidence there's no black hole
there okay Neil thanks for making me
feel
important than I already do knowing that
I'm not the center of the universe but
wait a minute how about black holes at
the center of our galaxy we've got one
Andromeda's got one except there's this
bigger than ours we have a black hole
envy but that's another show I long ago
we didn't know if black holes would be
common in the Centers of galaxies with
the help of the Hubble telescope which
has good precise ways to look down in
the center every galaxy we've had the
capacity to check has revealed a black
hole to us thus we will extrapolate an
assert that a black hole is a natural
phenomena in the center of all galaxies
of the universe Neela's usual that's
fascinating we have time for one more
question and we're going to take a look
at some group comments but first let's
spin that wheel Dan Birmingham wants to
know what's the most exciting thing we
don't know about black holes there's
good theoretical ideas about what would
happen if you survive a trip through the
black hole and come out on the other
side all of our equations tell us that
an entire new space-time opens up for
you once you've left the universe you
were just in you will never return to it
but you'll enter another domain our
equations tell us it's there but there's
no way to test that and come back and
tell anybody about it so that remains
for me one of the most intriguing
mysteries of the universe is each black
hole a universe unto itself Chuck back
to you damn that is super cool I'm gonna
call that a black rabbit hole well Neil
we are out of time thanks for being here
buddy I happy to be with you chuck
always make sure you subscribe to start
talking Network on Facebook watch and
join the wheel of science group and
leave comments like Brian McReynolds who
says I have just started sneaking
science facts onto the dry-erase
announcement board at work so this will
give me some more ideas lol once you
find Brian and leave him some facts huh
thanks for watching guys we'll see you
next week on wheel of science
[Music]